this is the makeup artist that designed
this icon but until recently she was
virtually unknown the Gillman better
known as the Creature from the Black
Lagoon is my favorite Universal movie
monster and is a Timeless creature that
will forever haunt the halls of movie
monster Fame because of the hidden star
behind the creature makeup artist
Millicent Patrick before moving to
Universal Studios and designing special
effects and makeup Millicent was a
skilled visual artist working for Disney
as an animator and in 1954 Millicent was
the artist who designed the Creature
from the Black Lagoon but when the film
came out she wasn't even credited for
her work her boss Bud Westmore was quite
jealous of Millicent's efforts and
abused his position to claim all the
credit Millicent would never work behind
the scenes on another film after that
and her name went unknown while her
creature inspired generations of
filmmakers now the truth has surfaced
from the murky Waters and Millicent
Patrick should get the credit she
deserves